This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和建立适应力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字 TWO 点几，在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。《Look Back at it》播客。从1979年开始，对当时的我和我来说，那是一个重要的时刻。1984年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。1984年是个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实都不太安全，但你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须要这样做。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。
Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners. ever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we have finally arrived at the lucky last in our birth order series. If you've been tuned in for a while over the last six months, I would say, we've done like a dedicated episode for every sibling in the family. So eldest, middle, youngest and in my last birth order episode I said the youngest child would be the last episode we would do and boy oh boy did I hear your outrage I heard and got so many DMs from you all and emails
欢迎回到播客节目。新听众，老听众。无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们要剖析我们20多岁时的心理。今天，我们终于迎来了出生顺序系列中幸运的最后一期。如果在过去六个月里你一直关注我们的节目，我想说的是，我们为家庭中的每一个兄弟姐妹都制作了一期专属节目。老大、老二、老小，在我的上一期关于出生顺序的节目中，我说过老小将是我们做的最后一期节目，天哪，我真的是听到了你们的愤怒，我收到了你们所有人发来的无数私信和电子邮件。
demanding that I do an episode on the youngest child and my friends I'm so sorry that I forgot about you but I have listened and I got my research into gear to deliver you the episode you all wanted so much. So for all of you who messaged me asking for this, I promise I did not forget, the only child is just so special that they needed their own dedicated week and dedicated episode. And here it is. This is it. With the amount of families, I think, choosing to have only one child in this day and age, honestly, we need to talk about it more, right? Because the research is getting more and more interesting by the day and more subjects are becoming available and only children are becoming so much more common. We've also had an entire country where they basically did an
强烈要求我做一期关于老小的节目，我的朋友们，我很抱歉我把你们给忘了，但我已经听取了意见，并开始着手进行研究，来为你们呈现这期大家如此期待的节目。所以对于所有给我发信息要求做这期节目的朋友们，我向你们保证我没有忘，独生子女实在是太特别了，他们需要有自己专属的一周和专属的节目。现在它来了。就是这个。考虑到如今选择只生一个孩子的家庭数量，老实说，我们确实需要对此进行更多的讨论，对吧？因为研究日渐引人入胜，越来越多的研究对象可供选择，独生子女也变得越来越普遍。我们甚至经历过一个国家，他们基本上对独生子女做过一个。
experiment on only children as in like you think about China's one child policy. They were like this perfect experimental condition where so many people obviously only had one child and it's this rare opportunity to really see how this experience of growing up, you know, as the only child, as the only child in the family normally with the full attention of your children. two parents does impact your personality. I also want to discuss some of the stereotypes about only children, the longstanding stereotypes, and how they are actually deeply incorrect and why they have come to be. We're also going to discuss Only Child and Parent dynamics, the pressure of needing to take care of your parents as you get older, parentification, also the different
关于独生子女的实验，比如你想想中国的独生政策。他们就像是这种完美的实验条件，因为显然有那么多人只生了一个孩子，这是一个难得的机会，可以真正地看一看这种成长经历，你知道的，作为一个独生子女，作为家里唯一的孩子，通常在父母双方的全力关注下，是如何影响你的个性的。我还想讨论一些关于独生子女的刻板印象，那些长期存在的刻板印象，以及它们为什么实际上大错特错，以及它们是如何形成的。我们还将讨论独生子女与父母的动态关系，随着年龄增长需要照顾父母的压力，父母化现象，还有可能影响独生子女经历的各种。
kinds of situations that may also impact the only child experience. So being the only child in a single person household, being the only child, but having step siblings, having lots of cousins. There's so many ways this can go. We're going to hopefully tackle every single one of them. You know I don't like to ramble too much at the beginning of these birth order episodes because I always end up spoiling some of the best parts in like the first five minutes. So I'm not going to do that here. I'm going to let the psychology and the research speak for itself. So without further ado, let's break down the unique and fascinating psychology of only children. So let's do a quick recap of birth order theory, the argument for it, but also against it.
情况。比如作为一个单亲家庭的独生子女，作为独生子女但有继兄弟姐妹，有很多表亲。这种情况有很多种可能。我们希望逐一探讨每一种情况。你知道我不太喜欢在这些出生顺序节目的开头唠叨太多，因为我总是最后在头五分钟左右就把一些最精彩的部分给剧透了。所以我在这里不会这样做。我要让心理学和研究本身来说话。所以废话不多说，让我们来剖析独生子女独特而迷人的心理。那么让我们快速回顾一下出生顺序理论，支持它的论点，以及反对它的论点。
If you are a loyal listener and you have kept up to date with the whole series, firstly, thank you so much. But secondly, this might sound just a wee bit repetitive because we have spoken about it a little bit. Feel free to jump ahead like five to seven minutes to where we get into the juicy stuff. But for those of you who don't know what birth order theory is, basically it is a major theory on human personality. Now, personality, we typically think of it as being shaped by two things, nature and nurture. So we are obviously a product of genetics, but we are also a product of parenting style and food and country of birth. and so many things, but essentially all the things that scientists and researchers believe impact
如果你是一个忠实的听众，并且一直跟进整个系列，首先，非常感谢。但其次，这听起来可能会有一点点重复，因为我们之前已经讨论过一些了。请随意快进大约五 到七分钟，直接跳到我们进入精彩内容的部分。但对于那些不知道什么是出生顺序理论的人来说，基本上它是关于人类个性的一大理论。现在，说到个性，我们通常认为它由两部分塑造，即先天与后天。所以我们显然是遗传的产物，但我们也是育儿风格、食物、出生国家以及许许多多事物的产物，但本质上，科学家和研究人员认为会影响。
our personality can either be from our environment or from our nature, so our genetic blueprint, who we were born to be. Now, the position we are born into in a family, and whether we have siblings or not, that is part of our environment and it falls into the nurture category. It influences our personality because of how it impacts how we are raised and experience the world as children, which leaves an impression and impact that carries on into adulthood. The thing that really defines the only child experience is that they don't obviously have siblings. It's their, I guess, solitude, isolation, their singularity. That is the thing that is the kind of point of fascination for,
我们个性的所有因素，要么来自我们的环境，要么来自我们的天性，也就是我们的基因蓝图，即我们生来是怎样的人。现在，我们在家庭中出生的位置，以及我们是否有兄弟姐妹，这是我们环境的一部分，属于后天培养的范畴。它通过影响我们的抚养方式以及作为儿童体验世界的方式来影响我们的个性，这会留下延续到成年期的印记和影响。真正定义独生子女经历的是，他们显然没有兄弟姐妹。这是他们的，我猜，孤独、孤立，他们的独特性。这就是让许多研究人员着迷的地方。只有他们自己。因此，我们对可能影响独生子女个性的因素的考察，归结为兄弟姐妹的缺失，而不是像老大、中间孩子和老小那样由于兄弟姐妹的存在而产生的影响。所以回到这个理论，创立出生顺序理论的人名叫阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒，他在他那个时代以很多成就闻名。你可能因为自卑情结而听说过他。
for a lot of researchers. It is just them. And so our examination of what might influence the personality of an only child comes down to the absence of siblings rather than the presence of siblings as it does for eldest, middle, and youngest children. So back to this theory, the man who developed birth order theory was a man named Alfred Adler and he was known for a lot of things in his time. You may have heard of him because of the inferiority complex.
那是他另一个著名的概念。他在20世纪中叶非常活跃，但出生顺序理论可能是他最广为人知的成就。再说一次，它基本上表明，作为老大、老小、中间孩子或独生子女，会影响你随着时间推移发展出哪些特征和特质，无论是在你还是孩子、青少年以及成年的时候。让我们非常非常明确一点。出生顺序理论不是一项医疗。
that's one of the other famous ones. He was very busy during the mid-1900s, but birth order theory is probably what he's most well known for. And again, it basically says that being the oldest, youngest, middle, or only child will affect what characteristics and traits you develop over time, both when you are a child, when you're a teenager, and as an adult. Let's be very, very clear. Birth order theory is not a medical procedure.
描述。它不会为你提供任何形式的心理学诊断。它是一个理论，而且是一个存在漏洞的理论，像任何其他理论一样存在例外和缺陷，你知道的，针对这个理论的大型科学研究真的很难进行。2015年确实进行了一项研究，结果发现很难获得足够多样化的人群，或者获得足够多愿意参与的人，来真正有时候得出结论。因此，我们需要小心，不要仅仅根据他们在家庭中出生的位置以及他们是否有兄弟姐妹来给人们贴上刻板标签。我认为在节目开头指出这一点是很有价值的。
description. It is not going to offer you any kind of psychological diagnosis. It is a theory and a theory with gaps at that with exceptions with flaws like any other theory and you know large scientific studies on this theory are really difficult to conduct. One did take place in 2015 and it did find that it's very hard to get a diverse enough amount of people or to get enough people who want to participate to really sometimes draw conclusions. And so we do need to be careful about pigeonholing people purely based on the position in the family they were born in and whether or not they have siblings. I think that's worth noting at the top of the episode.
今天你们会听到很多观点。它们并不是死板的观点。它们并不能完全决定你是一个什么样的人。在我看来，讨论出生顺序理论其实和讨论性格测试起到相同的作用。它们真的很有趣，很有用，而且它们确实为更好地理解我们在与他人关系中的定位提供了一个结构或指南。它们确实帮助我们更好地理解我们自身的特质，以及那些我们可能没有考虑过的关于我们自身行为方式的事情。但是，做完一个性格测试，然后说，好吧，这就是我这一生全部的模样了，这并不是最健康的做法。听一期这样的节目然后说，好吧，我是一个独生子女，这就是我的命运，同样也不是最健康的。我在讨论出生顺序理论时总是想保持某种谨慎，因为它确实存在于一个由诸多因素、想法、事件、情况组成的更庞大的生态系统中，这些因素共同影响了我们为什么会成为现在的样子。不过就我个人经验而言，我是老大，我是大女儿，我发现人们对老大的一些看法确实很符合我的情况。
You're going to hear a lot of ideas today. They are not strict ideas. They do not determine exactly the person you are. In my mind, discussing birth order theory really fills the same role. as talking about personality tests. They're really fun, they're useful, and they do provide a structure or guide for better understanding where we sit in relation to others. And they do help us better understand the traits within ourselves and the things that we
而且人们对我中间的妹妹和小妹妹的看法也确实很符合她们的情况。所以从轶事来看，我确实倾向于相信该理论的一些主张。但现在让我们转向节目的主角——独生子女。让我们从探讨刻板印象开始，或者流行文化对独生子女有何看法，以及他们通常是如何被描绘的。你可能经常听到的独生子女被描绘或预期的特征，通常基于这样一个事实，即他们是家里唯一的孩子。由于他们的家庭动态或结构，独生子女通常 A，花更多时间独自一人，其次，B，与有兄弟姐妹的人相比，花更多时间与成年人相伴。因为他们是父母唯一的孩子，我们也预期他们会得到更多的关注。
may not have considered about the way we are. But taking a personality test and then saying, well, that's everything I'm ever going to be, is not the healthiest thing. Neither is listening to an episode like this and saying, okay, well, I'm an only child, this is my destiny. I always want to be somewhat cautious when discussing birth order theory because it does exist in a much larger ecosystem of factors, ideas, events, situations that impact why we are the way we are. In my personal experience, though, I am the eldest child, I'm the eldest daughter, and I have found that a lot of what people say about me as an oldest child does really apply.
你知道，一个有两个、三个或四个兄弟姐妹的人很少能长时间独享父母双方的全部关注，但对于独生子女来说，这可能相当普遍。这有很多好处，但也有一些坏处，我们稍后会讨论。这不仅是时间投入，还有金钱、照顾、资源、陪伴，所有这些都容易让人觉得独生子女相当被娇惯。他们相当娇惯。他们有点像小 diva（爱发脾气的人）。这就是我们通常认为的形象。老实说，我觉得这挺搞笑的。就像，你知道的，从父母那里得到更多的爱不知怎么成了一件坏事，而且好像把你给娇惯坏了。就像，我实在看不出这到底。
and a lot of what people say about my middle sister and my younger sister also really apply. So anecdotally, I do tend to believe some of the theory's propositions. But let's now turn to the star of the show, The Only Child. Let's start by talking about the stereotypes or what pop culture would have to say about only children and how they're routinely depicted. The portrayed or expected traits of an only child that you might commonly hear about are typically based on the fact that they are the only child in the house. Because of their family dynamic or structure, only children typically spend A, more time alone, and second to that, B, more time in the company of adults compared to someone with siblings. because they are their parents' only child, we also expect that they get more attention.
怎么就合乎逻辑了，就像“哦，你得到的爱更多，去你的吧，你有什么毛病”，你知道我的意思吗，但这有时正是人们倾向于认为的，而且你知道，与有兄弟姐妹的人相比，人们可能会称之为过度放纵。人们真的暗示过，当这些孩子与其他孩子在一起时，这种过度放纵、被娇惯的本性尤其明显，因为他们没有学会如何分享，没有学会如何妥协，他们习惯了想要什么就得到什么。这就是独生子女的总体形象。让我们花点时间来打破这个假设的迷思，因为事实证明这其实没有任何科学依据。这毫无根据。
You know, someone with two or three or four siblings will rarely have the undivoted attention of both parents for very long, but for an only child, that might be quite typical. It has a lot of upsides, it also has some downsides, which we'll talk about later. It's not just the time commitment, it's also money, care, resources, presence, all of those things kind of lead people to think of only children as quite spoiled. They're quite spoiled. They're a little bit diva-ish. That's kind of the profile that we typically think of. I honestly think that's kind of funny. Like, you know, having more love from your parents is somehow a bad thing and like makes you spoiled. Like, I don't see how exactly that
独生子女并没有被更娇惯，也没有更自命不凡。这种理论或神话中的刻板印象实际上可以追溯到美国和欧洲二战后出生率下降时期的宣传。人口增长停滞或下降，这些政府需要说服人们尽可能多地生孩子。现在，他们通过几种方式做到这一点，其中一种方法本质上是制造这种想法或推广这样一项研究，即如果你只生一个孩子，你的孩子最后会变得嫉妒心强、自私、支配他人、非常嫉妒，
like makes sense like oh you have more love like fuck you like what's your problem you know what i mean but that's sometimes what people tend to think and you know in comparison to someone with siblings people might call that overindulged people have really suggested that this is particularly evident this overindulged spoiled nature when these children are around other kids because they haven't learned how to share they haven't learned how to compromise they're used to getting what they want That's the general profile of the only child. Let's myth bust this assumption for a second because it turns out this actually has no scientific basis. This has no basis.
他们最终会成为一个不懂得如何行为举止的人。而且，在当时，礼貌简直就是一切。所以这确实在一定程度上吓唬了人们，让他们觉得，如果我不给我的孩子一个兄弟姐妹，我真的是在给他们一个美好的生活吗？他们到底是从哪里得到这个想法的呢？嗯，根据美国心理学协会的说法，它来自于1900年代末的一篇论文，我想是1898年，题为《关于特殊和优秀儿童的研究》。这项研究是基于当时一位精神病医生的观察，他看到了一群孩子，并报告说他越来越频繁地只看到独生子女。
Only children are not more spoiled, they're not more stuck up. This stereotype in theory or myth actually dates back to propaganda used during an era in the US and in Europe where birth rates were declining after World War II. population growth was stagnant or had fallen and these governments needed to convince people to have as many babies as possible. Now they did this in a few ways and one way that they did do it was by essentially creating this idea or promoting this research that if you only have one child, your child is going to end up jealous, selfish, dominating other people, very jealous,
他的大部分客户都是独生子女。他得出的结论是，既然有这么多独生子女需要来看他，他们必定特别面临我们现在所说的、当时被称为神经质的风险，也就是我们现在所说的心理健康不佳或精神疾病。这就是他从自己所看到的50到70名客户的浅薄观察中得出的结论。现在，对于我的心理学学生来说，你们可能在这项研究中看到了巨大的问题，因为这是一个极好的例子，展示了当你没有控制好你的无关变量和混杂变量时会发生什么。
they're going to end up as someone who doesn't know how to behave. And, you know, back then, manners were literally everything. And so that did kind of scare people into thinking, well, am I really giving my child a good life if I'm not giving them a sibling? Where did they even get this idea from? Well, according to the American Psychological Association, it came from a paper from the end of the 1800s, I think 1898, titled, a study of peculiar and exceptional children. And this study was based on the observations of a psychiatrist at the time who saw a bunch of kids and reported that more and more he only saw only children.
并且你没有一个适当的随机样本。这个人所有的结论都仅仅基于他在自己非常小的诊所里看到的情况。事实证明，这种趋势出现的原因、他为什么会看到那么多独生子女，其实有一个更合理的解释。并不是因为没有兄弟姐妹的孩子更有问题或适应不良。仅仅是因为他们的父母高度警惕，
The majority of his clients were only children. And he concluded that given so many of these only children needed to see him, they must be particularly at risk of what we would nowadays, what was then called neuroticism, what we would now call poor mental health or mental illness. So that's what he kind of drew from his shallow observations of the 50 to 70 clients that he saw. Now for my psychology students, you are probably seeing some huge problems with this study because this is a great example of what happens when you don't control for your extraneous and confounding variables
他们所有的注意力都集中在这个孩子身上，如果他们看到了什么他们无法理解或难以处理的事情，他们就会寻求帮助来试图理解它，你知道的，如果你有四个、五个、七个孩子，那就难得多。要想仅仅注意到不快乐的微小时刻或你认为需要解决的小怪癖就难得多。很多东西都在噪音和忙碌中迷失了。事实上，事实是这样的：由于父母全神贯注的馈赠，独生子女在生命早期往往拥有更先进的语言和推理能力，在智商测试中表现更好。有时这实际上也会让他们感到不知所措，因为存在着巨大的成功和做好的压力，我们显然会在稍后讨论到这一点，但本质上。
and you don't have a proper randomized sample. This man was basing all of his conclusions only on what he saw at his very small practice. And it turns out there was a much more plausible explanation for why this trend had emerged, why he was seeing so many only children. It wasn't because kids without siblings were more troubled or maladjusted. It was simply because their parents were highly vigilant,
成为独生子女与我们的特权意识水平或诸如此类的事情之间没有任何相关性。事实上，为了给你提供进一步的证据，不久前阿拉巴马大学进行了一项研究，研究人员找了将近9,000名大学生，并实施了我们所说的自恋测量或测量，抱歉，或者一个自恋测试。所以基本上，他们让所有这些学生参与，并说，我们要给你们做几个测验，我想其中之一就是自恋测试。结果没有任何不同。而在该测试中被贴上自恋者标签的表现也没有任何差异。
all of their focus was on this kid and if they saw something they couldn't understand or had trouble dealing with they sought help to try and comprehend it you know if you have four five seven children that's so much harder to do it's so much harder to just notice small moments of unhappiness or small quirks that you think need addressing a lot of that gets lost in the noise and the busyness actually this is the truth only children tend to have more advanced lingual and reasoning skills and do better on IQ tests early in life because of the gift of their parents full attention this can also sometimes be actually overwhelming for them because there's a lot of pressure to succeed and to do well which we will obviously get to a little bit later on but essentially
在作为独生子女长大的人与有兄弟姐妹长大的人之间。同样，1987年对141项关于16种不同个性特质的研究进行的定性回顾也没有。
there is no correlation between being an only child and our level of entitlement or anything like that. In fact, to give you further evidence of this, a study was conducted at the University of Alabama a little while ago, and the researchers got almost 9,000 college students and administered what we call a measure of narcissism or a measure, sorry, or a narcissism test. So basically, they had all these students and they said, we're going to give you a couple of quizzes, I guess, one of which was a narcissism test. And there was no different. And there was no difference in performance on that test who was labelled a narcissist
支持“独生子女更适应不良、被娇惯、有特权意识且需要更多溺爱”的观点。没有任何证据，完全没有任何证据。那么，既然我们已经摆脱了那些迷思，我们对独生子女的个性了解多少呢？首先，我们知道独生子女通常在情感和社交上更敏感、更成熟。如果你在成长过程中大部分时间都与成年人在一起，你就会模仿他们的。
between people who grew up as an only child versus people who grew up with siblings. Similarly, a 1987 qualitative review of 141 studies on 16 different personality traits also failed
行为并向他们学习社交线索，就像你在其他情况下会模仿兄弟姐妹或其他孩子的行为一样。因此，独生子女很早就学会了如何与成年人相处。他们拥有更高级的社交技能，这在他们长大成为青少年、二十多岁和成年人时是一个巨大的优势，因为他们在成年世界中相处的社交敏感性通常发育得更完善。有时这实际上会使他们更难与同龄人交朋友，或与同龄人约会，或仅仅感觉自己还是个孩子，并真正沉浸在他们所处的年龄和阶段中。你知道，你可能18岁、19岁、21岁，每个人都出去喝酒，而你可能觉得你不是为这个而生的，因为你长期以来一直拥有这种先进的成熟感。独生子女通常也是完美主义者，这与老大非常相似。事实上，老大和独生子女有很多相似的特征和经历，这就是为什么我认为我能如此深刻地理解独生子女，因为，你知道的，老大在他们的兄弟姐妹到来并让他们成为老大之前，在某个阶段也曾是独生子女。
to support the opinion that only children are more maladjusted, spoil entitled and need more pampering. There was no evidence, no evidence that at all. So what do we know about the personalities of only children now that we've gotten over those myths? Well first off, we know that only children are typically more emotionally and socially sensitive and mature. If you spend most of your time with adults growing up, you mimic their
所以我们的早期经历可能非常相似，而且独生子女和老大通常都会发现他们面临来自父母的巨大成功压力，因为父母的许多希望和梦想都寄托在他们身上。他们可能面临更大的学业压力、更大的身体压力，所有这些压力。你的父母，我猜之所以会这样，是因为你的父母，虽然我很讨厌用这个词，但它确实是最容易做到的。如果你是独生子女，他们没有备选方案。因此，他们所有的野心都集中在你身上。
behavior and learn social cues from them the way that you otherwise would have mimicked the behavior of siblings or other children. So only children learn very early on how to get along with adults. They have more advanced social skills and that is a huge advantage as they grow up and they become teenagers and 20 somethings and adults because their social sensitivity for getting along in the adult world is typically more well developed. Sometimes that can actually make it harder for them to make friends with people their own age or to date people their own age or to just feel like a kid and really sink
这是很自然的，你知道的，即使是那些没有大声说出来的父母，内心深处也仍然秘密地希望他们的孩子成功，不仅是为了孩子好，也是为了他们可以这样说：“嘿，看那个，这就是证明我是一个好父母、我做得很好的证据，因为我的孩子成功了。”通常情况下，这种压力会被分散到几个孩子身上，如果你没有其他兄弟姐妹，那就意味着这一切都将集中在你一个人身上，而这带来了巨大的压力。这会转化为非常高的个人期望，我相信不用我重复第二遍。事实上，1987年那项反驳了独生子女被宠坏的小霸王神话的同一项研究确实发现，他们确实拥有更高的与成就相关的动机和更高水平的完美主义。
deeply into the age and phase they are at. You know, you might be 18, 19, 21 and everyone's going out and getting drunk and you might not feel like you're made for that because you've had this advanced sense of maturity for so long. Only children are also typically perfectionist, very similar to eldest children. Actually, eldest and only children share a lot of similar traits and experiences, which is why I think I get only children so deeply, because, you know, an eldest child has at some stage been the only child before their siblings came along and made them the eldest.
这可能很难管理，而且不仅是父母在给我们施加压力，最终我们自己也开始给自己施加压力，觉得产出和我们取得的任何成就就是我们全部的价值所在。不过，这里有一些稍微好一点的消息。独生子女其实对自己的陪伴更满足。这太棒了。在这个许多人都在谈论我们正在经历孤独流行的时代，能够享受自己的陪伴和空间100%是一项资产。我在研究这期节目时发现了一个非常吸引人的研究，那就是独生子女在小时候更有可能有想象中的朋友来。
So our early experiences are probably very similar, and the only child and eldest child typically do both find that they face extreme pressure from their parents to be successful because a lot of their hopes and dreams ride on them. They might face greater academic pressure, greater physical pressure, all these kinds of things. Your parents, I guess the reason why this happens is because your parents, and I hate to use this phrase, but it does come easiest. If you're an only child, they don't have a backup. And so all their ambitions are concentrated in you.
娱乐自己。随着我们长大，我们体内那些可以想象各种事物来让我们保持忙碌、娱乐和快乐的部分并不会消失。所以我们可以变得相当有创意。事实上，如果你是独生子女，请让我知道。告诉我你在成长过程中是否有任何想象中的朋友，以及他们的名字是什么，这样你可以帮我证实这些发现，你知道我真的非常喜欢听人们谈论这个，因为孩子们真的很疯狂，他们拥有最疯狂的想象力。当我还是个孩子，在我的妹妹们出生之前，我当了五年独生子女时，我确实有一个想象中的朋友叫奥斯兰（Oslan），他是一头狮子，他住在由我创造的这片土地上，每当我睡觉时，他就会从那片土地来到这里，睡在我的。
it's only natural you know even parents who don't say it out loud still secretly want their child to succeed not just for their child's sake but also so they can kind of say hey look at that here's proof that i was a good parent that i did a good job because my child has succeeded normally that is diffused over a couple of children and if you don't have any other siblings it means that it's all going to be concentrated on you and that is a whole lot of pressure that translates to very high personal expectations, which I'm sure I don't have to tell you twice. In fact, the same study from 1987 that disproved the spoilt brat myth about only children did find that they do possess higher achievement-related motivation and higher levels of perfectionism.
衣柜里照顾我。我对他的记忆如此鲜明。我说的是记忆，对吧？就像，这并不是我们凭空捏造的记忆。对这个角色的生动愿景。有时感觉就像一部电影。所以，如果你能感同身受，并且在成长过程中有一个想象中的朋友，请在下面的评论中留下他们的名字。告诉我们关于这个想象中的朋友的事。让他们的传说也在我们的脑海中延续下去。如果你还没猜到的话，独生子女也正因为如此而相当有创意，并且相当独立。事实上，大多数独生子女都会说他们更喜欢独自完成任务。这带来的一个负面影响是，有时他们在共同决策时可能会挣扎，不是因为他们专横或傲慢，不，而是因为他们在成长过程中没有。
That can be very difficult to manage, and it's not just that our parents, are putting pressure on us, but that eventually we do begin to put pressure on ourselves and feel like output and whatever we produce achievements is all we are worth. Here's some slightly better news, though. Only children are actually more content with their own company. So that's great. In a day and age when, you know, a lot of people are saying we're experiencing a loneliness epidemic, being able to enjoy your own company and space is one 100% an asset. There was a really fascinating study I actually discovered in researching this episode that only children are actually more likely to have imaginary friends when they're younger to
做过太多这样的事情。他们可能会发现很难妥协，而通过发现很难妥协，我的意思是他们要么付出太多，要么妥协太少。在共享决策或共同决策方面的挣扎可能会影响某些人长期的恋爱关系。现在，我要花一会儿时间来谈谈接下来的这项研究。请对它保持保留态度。记住我们在节目开头说过的话，这不是命运。但一项使用了芝加哥大学国家民意研究中心在以下时间之间收集的超过57,000人的数据的研究，我想大约是40年间，从70年代到2010年代，他们确实发现独生子女比有兄弟姐妹的人稍微更有可能。
entertain themselves. And as we grow up, the parts of us that can imagine things to keep us busy and entertained and happy, they don't go away. So we can become quite creative. Actually, if you are an only child, please let me know. Tell me if you had any imaginary friends growing up and like what their names were so you can help me confirm some of these findings you know i love hearing about this from people because kids are seriously they have the craziest imaginations when i was a kid before my sisters were born and i was an only child for five years i did have an imaginary friend called oslan who was a lion and he lived in this land i had created and he would come from that land and like sleep in my
离婚，并将此归因于在共同决策方面存在困难。所以他们在研究中发现的是，每多一个兄弟姐妹，离婚的几率就会降低3%左右。听起来非常显著，但有很多兄弟姐妹的人结婚的可能性也更低。我还想说，这是来自57,000人的数据。听起来确实很多人，但这跨越了40,000年，并且是汇总数据。它并不是针对你个人的处方。因为在这个群体中，也有很多独生子女，他们的婚姻绝对美满。所以它是有局限性的，它只是数据。它讲述了一个故事，但不一定是你的故事。因此，考虑到所有这些，如果我们把所有这些发现放在一起，然后进一步深入挖掘，
closet when I was going to sleep and take care of me. I have such vivid memories of him. And I say memories, right? Like, it's not like we made these memories. Such vivid visions of this character. Sometimes it feels like a movie. So if you can relate and you had an imaginary friend growing up, drop their name in the comment below. Tell us about this imaginary friend. Let their like legend live on in our minds as well. Only children, if you hadn't already guessed it as well, are quite creative because of this and quite independent. In fact, most only children will say they prefer to complete tasks alone. One downside of this is that sometimes they can struggle with joint decision making not because they are bossy or arrogant, no, but because they just haven't had to
作为独生子女，它预示着什么，或者可能告诉了我们关于自己的什么，从约会到职业再到亲子关系？我们挣扎的是什么？我们在这里要休息一小会儿，但当我们回来时，我们还有更多内容要揭示和讨论。所以请继续收听。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占比率。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、
do it so much growing up. They can find it hard to compromise and by finding it hard to compromise, and by finding it hard to compromise, I mean they can either give way too much or give in too little. A struggle with shared decision making or joint decision making could impact some people's long-term relationships. Now, I'm going to talk about this next study for a second. Please take it with a grain of salt. Remember what we said at the top of the episode, this is not destiny. But a study using data for more than 57,000 people. collected by the University of Chicago's National Opinion Research Center between, I think it was like 40 years or like the 70s and the 2010s, they did find that only children were slightly more likely
体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立适应力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越那些浮于表面。且过于复杂的伪科学，正是这些伪科学主导了健康产业。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
to get divorced than people with siblings and they attributed it to difficulty with shared decision making. So what they found in their study or their research was that each additional sibling is associated with a 3% drop in chance of divorce. Sounds very significant, but people with lots of siblings are also less likely to get married. I'll also say this is from 57,000 people. That does sound like a lot of people, but that is over 40,000 years and it's aggregated. And it's not a prescription to you and you only. Because within that group, there were also a lot of only children whose marriages were absolutely incredible. So it is limited and it's just data. It tells a story, but not necessarily your story. So with all of this in mind, if we put all these findings together and then dig even deeper,
收听《2%》。也就是 T-W-O-Percent，在 I-Heart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcast，或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得 Diana Ross 在 VMA 上拍了 Little Kim 的胸部两次吗？或者当 Kanye 说 George Bush 不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。George Bush 跟 Little Kim 有什么鬼关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是 Sam Jett。
what does being an only child predict or maybe tell us about ourselves from dating to careers to parent-child relationships? And what do we struggle with? We're going to go on a tiny little break here, but when we return, we have so much more to uncover and discuss. So please stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
我是 Alex English。每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请 Mark Lamont Hill 的节目，畅谈80年代的瘾品。澄清一下，1984年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为瘾品。我随时准备一整天都在谈论瘾品，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，到目前为止，马克，这是我们讨论瘾品的第二集了。
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractors. and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在台面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple、podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师 Kear Gaines。为了纪念心理健康宣传月，我将我十多年来在心理健康领域的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带到了节目中。我说的是，Tripp Fontaine，Ryan Clark。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入到追逐之中，以至于我们。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们仍然在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于胜利和失败。Steve Burns，Dustin Ross，因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要？
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，Kear Gaines，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索 Learn the hard way 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她说法中前后矛盾的明显破绽。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple, podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在 iHeart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。所以出生顺序理论吸引人的很大一部分原因在于，有些人声称它可以预测你生活的方方面面，比如你应该和什么样的人约会，你会和谁在一起最幸福，你在什么工作中会最幸福。我并不是100%确信。因为总是有例外，但出生顺序理论做出的一些预测确实。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure,
准得吓人。所以让我们来谈谈它对独生子女的看法。谈到独生子女的约会，我们在本集中已经多次提到这一点，老大和独生子女通常都在追求相似的东西。而且他们追求的往往是与他们相反的东西。所以在出生顺序理论中存在着非常强烈的“异性相吸”模式。所以理论上讲，独生子女倾向于被老小吸引，特别是如果你是一个喜欢男人的女性，你会被最小的儿子吸引；或者如果你是一个喜欢女人的男性，你大概能明白，你会被老小吸引。
and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
当老大和独生子女可能相当成熟、有责任感、是完美主义者、高产时，我们寻求平衡并且非常冷静成熟。这一点有时会得到那些随和、活泼、神经质较少、轻松愉快的人的补充，比如老小。根据詹妮弗·哈特斯坦（Jennifer Hartstein）博士这篇非常精彩的文章，她是一名专门从事儿童、青少年和家庭心理治疗的专家。独生子女非常明智且认真。所以他们通常喜欢在恋爱关系中掌控大局，但老小的冒险精神和自发性意味着他们确实能够互补。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
独生子女在约会时会与谁发生冲突？嗯，是长子或独生子女吗？是老大吗？因为你把这两个固执己见、自主性强的人放在了一起。有时他们忘记了共同合作的重要性，因为他们太习惯于。独立行事，并希望自己做事情或掌控大局。在恋爱关系中有两个这样的人是很困难的。请记住，任何两个人都是可以相容的。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So a big part of birth order theories appeal is that some people claim it can predict aspects of your life, like what kind of person you should date, who you'd be happiest with, what job you'd be happiest in. I'm not 100% convinced. because there are always exceptions, but some of the predictions made by birth order theory are
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对应有的惩罚。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因涉嫌欺诈已被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。出生顺序理论吸引人的很大一部分原因在于，有些人声称它可以预测你生活的方方面面，比如你应该和什么样的人约会、和谁在一起会最幸福、从事什么工作会最幸福。我并非 100% 确信，因为总会有例外，但出生顺序理论所做的一些预测
actually scarily accurate. So let's talk about what it says about only children. When it comes to dating as an only child, and we've mentioned this a few times in this episode, eldest children and only children typically are after similar things. And often what they are after is what is opposite to them. So there's very much a strong opposites attract model going on in birth order theory. So the theory goes that only children gravitate towards lastborns, specifically if you're a woman who likes men, youngest sons, or if you're a man who likes women, you kind of get the picture, youngest children.
确实准得让人害怕。那么我们来谈谈它对独生子女的看法。说到独生子女的约会情况——我们在本期节目中已经多次提到这一点——老大和独生子女通常追求相似的东西。而且他们通常追求的是与他们相反的东西。因此，出生顺序理论中存在着非常强烈的“异性相吸”模式。该理论认为，独生子女往往会被老小吸引，特别是如果你是喜欢男生的女性，就会倾向于最小的儿子；或者如果你是喜欢女生的男性，你大概能明白我的意思，也就是最小的孩子。
Where elders and only children can be quite mature, responsible, we're perfectionists, we're productive, we seek out balance and we're very level-headed and mature. That is sometimes complimented by someone who is easygoing, who is lively, who is less neurotic, who is lighthearted, like a lastborn. According to this really fabulous article by Dr. Jennifer Hartstein, she's a specialist in psychotherapy for children, adolescents, and families. Only children are very sensible and conscientious. So they typically like to take charge in the relationship, but the adventurous nature of the lastborn and the spontaneity means that they do balance each other out.
老大和独生子女往往非常成熟、有责任感，我们是完美主义者，富有成效，追求平衡，而且非常冷静和成熟。随和、活泼、神经质较少、轻松愉快的人（比如老小）有时可以很好地与这种性格互补。根据儿童、青少年和家庭心理治疗专家詹妮弗·哈特斯坦博士（Dr. Jennifer Hartstein）的一篇非常精彩的文章，独生子女非常明智且尽责。因此，他们在恋爱关系中通常喜欢掌握主导地位，但老小的冒险天性和随性意味着他们确实能互相平衡。
Who do only children clash with in dating? Well, are the firstborns or only children? Are the eldest children? Because you're kind of putting these two opinionated, self-directed people together. And sometimes they forget that it's important to work together because they are so used to. to being independent and wanting to do things themselves or take charge. It's difficult to have two people like that in a relationship. Please keep in mind, any two people can be compatible.
独生子女在约会时与谁会有冲突？好吧，是头胎子女、独生子女还是老大？因为你把这两个都有主见、自主性强的人放在了一起。有时他们会忘记合作的重要性，因为他们太习惯于独立，习惯于凡事亲力亲为或掌控大局。两个这样的人在一起恋爱是很艰难的请记住，任何两个人都是可以相容的。
And if you are currently dating someone who is not a youngest child and you are an only child, do not go and break up with them. If you found love, you found love. It doesn't really matter where someone is in the family. If it works for you, it works for you because personality and relationships and intimacy and love in general are influenced. by so many things, but it is really interesting to see if this applies to you, who it applies to, and how we are continuously seeing these repeated relationship patterns between only children
如果你现在正在和非老幺约会，而你又是独生子女，千万不要去和他们分手。如果你找到了真爱，那就是真爱。一个人在家庭中的排行其实并不重要。如果你们相处融洽，那就说明合适，因为个性、人际关系、亲密感以及普遍的爱都会受到很多因素的影响，但了解这是否适用于你、适用于哪些人，以及我们如何不断看到独生子女之间不断重复的恋爱模式，真的是一件非常有趣的事情。
and certain other members or birth order types. Okay, let's shift gears. Let's talk about career. You know, if we care about love the most, we definitely care about career almost equally, if not second. If you are an only child, let's talk about the profile we have of you so far. You are probably very intellectual and intelligent. You are a high achiever.
以及某些其他成员或出生顺序类型。好了，我们转换一下话题。我们来聊聊职业。你知道，如果我们最看重爱情，那么我们几乎同样看重职业，即使不是排在第二位的话。如果你是独生子女，让我们来聊聊目前我们对你的画像。你可能非常具有求知欲和聪明才智。你是一个高成就者。
You're very logical. You take control. You're motivated. Maybe you're a little bit of a lone wolf. With that in mind, the potentially well-suited careers for only children as given by birth order theory include professions that require intellectual stimulation, strong analytical skills. or a path to success. So law, medicine or healthcare, science, engineering, technology, or business management, finance, all of these involve strategic thinking, all of them involve a lot of analytical work and focus,
你非常理性。你掌控全局。你很有动力。也许你有点像一匹孤狼。考虑到这一点，根据出生顺序理论，独生子女潜在最适合的职业包括需要智力刺激、强大分析能力或成功路径的职业。比如法律、医学或医疗保健、科学、工程、技术、或者商业管理、金融，所有这些都涉及到战略思维，所有这些都涉及到大量的分析工作和专注，
and there is a path to, of course, success. Thinking about the only children I know in my own life, personally, almost all, of them work in finance and law. Like, of course that is anecdotal, but in terms of this career stereotype, this is totally making sense for me in what I'm seeing in my own life. And all these skills make them such an asset in a team. You know, they make them such an asset as friends as well. Like the person who's going to come in with a game plan, the person who is level-headed in emotional situations, the person who is innovative, who is, responsible who is a problem solver, you know, as an eldest daughter, sometimes it's nice to have
当然，这也有一条通往成功的道路。回想一下我生活中认识的独生子女，我个人认识的几乎所有人都在金融和法律行业工作。这当然只是个人经验，但就这种职业刻板印象而言，这完全符合我在自己生活中所看到的情况。所有这些技能使他们在团队中成为宝贵的财富。你知道，这让他们作为朋友也非常宝贵。比如那个带着游戏计划出现的人，那个在情绪激动时保持冷静的人，那个富有创新精神的人，那个有责任感、能够解决问题的人，你知道，作为长女，有时能拥有
a little bit of a teammate, and normally that teammate is one of my only child friends. One thing that also impacts career choices and impacts in life paths, the life paths, I should say, of the only child is their parents and the fact that they feel a greater responsibility to their parents. So only children may actually find it harder to move away. for work. They may find it harder to travel and be spontaneous because there's greater guilt associated with leaving your parents alone considering you might sometimes feel like, oh, I'm all they have. I found this really interesting Reddit story actually discussing the burden of feeling like the sole caregiver for your parents as they get older and, you know, how hard it is to, I guess,
一个小队友感觉很好，通常那个队友就是我独生子女的朋友之一。同样影响职业选择和人生轨迹的因素之一——我应该说独生子女的人生轨迹——是他们的父母，以及他们对父母感到更强烈的责任感这一事实。因此，独生子女可能实际上会发现很难为了工作而搬到外地。他们可能会发现很难去旅行和说走就走，因为离开父母独处会产生更大的负罪感，考虑到你有时可能会觉得，哦，我是他们唯一的依靠。我其实在Reddit上看到了一个非常有趣的故事，讨论了随着父母年龄增长，感觉自己是父母唯一照顾者的负担，以及，你知道，去接受和承认他们正在变老这件事有多难，我想，
embrace and acknowledge the fact that they are aging. You know, when you have siblings, it is something that you can face together. And it's something whereby there is a sense of camaraderie around, okay, so what are we going to do with mom and dad? Or what if they're not okay? What if they need our help? You can manage it together. But for only children, it's just you. It's just you. And that can put a lot of pressure on your future plans. And, you, and you can put a lot of pressure on your future plans and how your parents factor in. So with that in mind, what else do only children struggle with as part of this unique birth order experience? If we're going all the way back to childhood, a lot of only children do report a sense of loneliness as children and really wanting to have
当你兄弟姐妹的时候，这是你们可以一起面对的事情。而且，围绕着“好吧，我们要拿爸爸妈妈怎么办？”或者“如果他们不好怎么办？如果他们需要我们的帮助怎么办？”这种问题，会有一种同甘共苦的感觉。你可以一起处理。但对于独生子女来说，只有你。只有你。这会给你的未来计划带来很大的压力。而且，你，这会给你的未来计划以及父母所占的比重带来很大的压力。因此，考虑到这一点，作为这种独特的出生顺序经历的一部分，独生子女还在与什么作斗争？如果我们一直追溯到童年，许多独生子女确实报告说在童年时期有一种孤独感，并且非常渴望拥有
siblings, sometimes feeling quite envious of large families, feeling envious of people who always had others around. They also. are more likely to have had to entertain themselves. That factors into the imaginary friends thing but yeah they spend a lot more time alone. There's goods and bads in that experience.
兄弟姐妹，有时会对大家庭感到相当嫉妒，对那些身边总是有人陪伴的人感到嫉妒。他们也。更有可能不得不自己娱乐自己。这与想象中的朋友有关，但是的，他们独自度过的时间要多得多。这种经历有好有坏。
We've spoken about both of them depending on your level of loneliness or isolation it's really up to you whether you think that was an asset or a downside. You as an only child were also more likely to have very over-involved
我们已经讨论了这两方面，根据你的孤独或孤立程度，你是否认为这是一笔财富还是一个缺点，完全取决于你。作为独生子女，你也更有可能有过度介入的
parents. Now when we get to teenagehood when we become adolescence, this can be a challenge during this time, during between the ages of like 13 and 18, we go through a period of development in which we really want to mark our own territory, create our own identity, be an individual, despite who our parents are. And so we can kind of push back against the authority or involvement of our parents and that can be very, very tricky when you are the only child because your parents are just in everything. They know everything about you. They're in all your business. There is no distractions. And so sometimes people do find that the pushback that is natural for
父母。现在，当我们进入青少年时期，当我们成为青少年时，这在这段时间可能会成为一个挑战，在大约13岁到18岁之间，我们会经历一个发展阶段，在这个阶段中，我们非常想要标明自己的地盘，创造自己的身份，成为一个独立的个体，不管我们的父母是谁。因此，我们可能会对父母的权威或介入进行某种程度的抗拒，而当你是个独生子女时，这可能会非常非常棘手，因为你的父母无所不在。他们对你了如指掌。他们介入了你所有的事务。没有任何干扰。因此，有时人们确实会发现，这种对于任何人在青少年时期都很自然的抗拒，
anyone in teenagehood, the push back against the parents feels like more of a point of tension and stress within your family because there's no one else to mitigate that. There's no one else to ease the tension. Another thing that only children struggle with is that they are more likely to be parentified. So parentification and psychology refers to the experience whereby the role of the child and the parent almost flips. So, you know, we would expect that the parent is the one who takes care of the child, not just physically, but emotionally and mentally as well. So the parent is the one who hears the concerns, who hears the troubles, and they then have their own support network to support them.
对父母的抗拒会变成家庭中更多紧张和压力的来源，因为没有其他人来缓解这种状况。没有其他人来缓和紧张气氛。独生子女苦恼的另一件事是，他们更有可能被“父母化”。因此，心理学中的“父母化”指的是这样一种经历：孩子和父母的角色几乎颠倒了。所以，你知道，我们原本期望父母是照顾孩子的人，不仅在身体上，在情感和精神上也是如此。因此，父母是倾听担忧、倾听烦恼的人，然后他们有自己的支持网络来支持他们。
Parentification occurs when a parent turns to their child and says, all right, you can be my problem solver. You can be the parent in this situation. Here are my problems. Here's what I'm worried about. Here's our financial concerns. Here's me and your dad or me and your mom's relationship problems. Fix them or hear about them and feel.
当父母向他们的孩子求助并说：“好吧，你可以成为我的问题解决者。在这个情况下你可以当家长。这是我的问题。这是我担心的事。这是我们的财务问题。这是我和你爸爸或我和你妈妈的关系问题。去解决它们，或者听我说这些然后觉得……”时，父母化就发生了。
like you need to fix them even if maybe that's not explicitly what I'm asking. Hopefully you kind of get my gist. The child becomes the parent and takes on the responsibilities of this role for the person who's meant to be doing it for them. Now if you are the only child, you are probably extra, extra, extra close to your parents. And so this parentification is more likely to occur. Those are some of the consequences of being an only child. loneliness, pressure, the burden of your parents aging, the burden of over-involved parents
即使这可能不是我明确要求的，你也觉得自己必须去解决它们。希望你大概能懂我的意思。孩子变成了父母，并为本该为他们做这件事的人承担起这个角色的责任。现在，如果你是独生子女，你可能与父母格外、格外、格外亲密。因此，这种父母化现象更有可能发生。这些就是作为独生子女的一些后果：孤独感、压力、父母衰老的负担、过度介入的父母带来的负担
and parentification. There are some other factors, though, that influence the only child experience such that you can be an only child, but experience it very differently to the next person because of the age of your parents. Maybe you are the only child in one family, but your parents separated and you have step-siblings. maybe you have a lot of cousins. And so I'm telling you all these things and facts about who you're meant to be and you're thinking,
以及父母化。不过，还有其他一些因素会影响独生子女的经历，让你虽然是独生子女，但由于父母的年龄，你所经历的可能与旁人截然不同。也许你是一个家庭中的独生子女，但你的父母离婚了，你有了继兄弟姐妹。也许你有很多表亲。所以，当我告诉你所有这些关于你应该成为什么样的人的事实和观点时，你可能会想：
none of this relates to me because actually you didn't have an only child experience. You had a very unique experience where, yes, you were the only technical child in your family, but you had a lot of other children around you. So if I were to compare you to an only child who lived in the rural countryside and only ever saw adults, compared to an only child who lives in the city and goes to like a big school and their cousins live next door, you are going to turn out differently. And it may explain why some of the only child traits that we typically expect aren't very common in large communities where children are raised by everyone. It gives the impression.
这些都与我无关，因为实际上你并没有过独生子女的经历。你有着非常独特的经历，是的，你在名义上是家里的独生子女，但你身边有很多其他孩子。因此，如果我把你和一个住在乡村田野、只见过成年人的独生子女进行比较，再和一个住在城市、去大学校上学且表亲就住在隔壁的独生子女进行比较，你们的成长结果会有所不同。这或许可以解释为什么我们在那些由所有人共同抚养孩子的大家庭中，通常不太常见到我们所期望的一些独生子女特质。这给人一种印象。
It gives the experience of growing up with a bunch of other people and having to factor in their person. their personalities and their desires in a way that a singular only child in a more isolated environment wouldn't have to do. There's one final unique experience that is quite sad and it's when you are an only child because your sibling has passed, that can give you some extreme survivor's guilt and all that pressure, all that expectation, the over-involved maybe helicopter nature of your parents can be exacerbated. The survivor's guilt in particular could be particularly strong if, you know, the passing of your sibling has made you an only child because now you really do feel like you have to
这给人一种与一群其他人一起长大，并且必须考虑到他们的个性的成长体验。他们的个性和愿望是以一种在更加孤立环境中的独生子女所不必做的方式进行的。最后还有一个独特的经历，相当悲伤，那就是当你成为独生子女是因为你的兄弟姐妹已经去世，这会给你带来一些极端的幸存者内疚，所有的压力、所有的期望，父母过度介入的直升机式教育特质可能会被加剧。幸存者内疚，特别是如果，你知道，你的兄弟姐妹的去世让你成了独生子女，因为现在你真的觉得你必须
make all of your experiences worth it. You have to live in life for both of you and you have to be two children for your parents almost. You have to make sure that you meet all their expectations. It's a very complex, a moment. emotional and psychological experience and we truly need to do a whole episode on it. So if that's something you would like, please reach out to me. So yeah, I can get a sense of it.
让你所有的经历都变得值得。你必须为你们两个人活着，你几乎必须为你的父母扮演两个孩子的角色。你必须确保你达到他们所有的期望。这是一个非常复杂、情绪化和心理上的经历，我们真的需要做一整期节目来探讨它。所以，如果你想听这个，请联系我。这样我就能有个大致的概念。
Again, we should avoid overgeneralizing about an only child and who they will become. But something I do want us to all come away with is that being an only child, you know, this was once a unique and somewhat stigmatized experience. now it's becoming not only so much more common, but it's an asset. Without a doubt, only children are such an asset. I say this all the time, but no one's personality has no value. Each of us fills a space society needs to be filled. We need different ways of thinking and seeing the world.
同样，我们应该避免对独生子女以及他们将成为什么样的人进行过度概括。但我想让大家明白的一点是，作为独生子女，你知道，这曾经是一种独特且带有某种污名化的经历。现在它不仅变得越来越普遍，而且成了一种优势。毫无疑问，独生子女是一笔巨大的财富。我经常这样说，但没有人的个性是没有价值的。我们每个人都填补了社会需要填补的空间。我们需要不同的思维方式和看世界的视角。
We need different ways of problem solving, a lot of which is brought on by our different childhood environments and personalities and experiences. There's a great book actually by an environmental scientist slash activist called Bill McKibben, and he basically argues that more people should be considering only having one child, and that we should ignore this idea that they are lonely or difficult or selfish because the research proves time and time again that, in general, they're not more, any more of these things compared to the average child. And even if these are experiences you sometimes have, where you are lonely or you do struggle
我们需要不同的问题解决方式，其中很多是由我们不同的童年环境、个性和经历带来的。事实上，有一本非常棒的书，作者是一位名叫比尔·麦基本（Bill McKibben）的环境科学家兼活动家，他的基本论点是，更多的人应该考虑只生一个孩子，我们应该忽略那种认为他们孤独、难缠或自私的观点，因为研究一次又一次地证明，总体而言，与普通孩子相比，他们并没有表现出更多这些特质。即使这些是你有时会有的经历，比如感到孤独或确实在
with working with other people, actually in the large part of this debate, the debate of is it worth only having one child, most people will say the benefits totally outweigh any downsides and being an only child is actually quite a favourable childhood environment because here you are with all the love and attention and resources of two parents or even one parent who is incredibly devoted to you and thinks you are incredible. Okay guys, we've talked about a lot so far, but we always have time for more and we always have time for our listener questions to touch on the more niche parts of this topic. can't always get to. So go have a little tea break, have a little pause, and we will be right
与其他人合作时感到挣扎，实际上在这个辩论的大部分时间里，也就是“只生一个孩子是否值得”的辩论中，大多数人会说，好处完全超过了任何缺点，作为独生子女实际上是一个相当有利的童年环境，因为在这里你拥有两个父母甚至是一个对你极其投入、认为你无与伦比的父母所有的爱、关注和资源。好了，伙计们，到目前为止我们已经聊了很多，但我们总是有时间聊更多，我们总是有时间回答听众的问题，来触及这个话题中那些我们无法总是涉及的更小众的部分。所以去喝杯茶休息一下，暂停一会儿，我们马上
back. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look for. past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
回来。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以探寻。超越那些统治着健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油本身就会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jek.
收听《2%》。也就是I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的T-W-O-Persent。还记得黛安·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·杰克（Sam J.）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·hill（Mark Lamont Hill），畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅因为快克。我随时准备聊聊关于快克的事，只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们第二次讨论快克了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在台面上了。谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we, are in possession of the thing, and we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西，而我们还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure and purpose on my new podcast,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）一起，在我的新播客中进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。
Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
《Learn the Hardway》。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Lens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of Internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
这引发了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。兰斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支由网络侦探组成的军队来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税金是用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news out of Maricopa County as, Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When I posted on my Instagram story that I was doing an episode on Only Children, I already said you guys went nuts for it. And I got so many questions. So many brilliant questions. Thank you so much.
女士们先生们，来自马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当我把关于我正在制作一期关于独生子女的节目的内容发到Instagram快拍上时，我已经说过你们对此疯狂了。我收到了太多的问题。太多精彩绝伦的问题。非常感谢。
It was very, very hard to choose, but we're just going to do four or five today and, yeah, really sink our teeth into them. I really loved this first question because I didn't really hear anyone else ask about this, but I feel like it's something that might be a common difficulty. So this is the question. How do you learn how to deal with fights and drama between siblings when you're an only child? because my boyfriend and his sister fight constantly and it bothers me so much. I had never thought about this. If you are an only child, you have never had to deal with having savage fights with your siblings. Now, I'm guessing you can tell by the way I said that, it's actually totally normal.
要选择真的非常非常难，但我们今天只挑四个或五个，然后，是的，好好深入探讨一下。我真的很喜欢第一个问题，因为我没有听到其他人问过这个，但我觉得这可能是个常见的难点。所以问题是这样的：当你是个独生子女时，你是如何学会处理兄弟姐妹之间的争吵和戏剧性事件的？因为我男友和他姐姐经常吵架，这让我非常烦恼。我从来没想过这个问题。如果你是独生子女，你从来不用去处理跟兄弟姐妹进行残酷争吵的事情。现在，我猜从我的说话方式你就能听出来，这其实完全是正常的。
To a degree, obviously. If it is toxic and unsustainable and tearing a relationship apart and if it's continuing, way into adulthood and unnecessarily lengths and frequency and intensity, probably not good, but the average sibling fight is pretty short-lived and it can seem really intense, but it's not because we have had so much, we've had so much practice, we've had so much practice fighting with each other and getting on each other's nerves. Sometimes it's just a way of releasing tension, sometimes even like having a little fight or bigger with your sibling is kind of a sign of love.
在某种程度上，显然如此。如果这种关系有毒、不可持续、正在撕裂一段关系，并且如果它一直持续到成年期，还带有不必要的时长、频率和强度，那可能就不好，但一般的兄弟姐妹争吵通常都很短暂，而且看起来可能非常激烈，但并非如此，因为我们已经经历过太多，我们已经有了太多练习，我们已经有了很多互相争吵和惹恼彼此的练习。有时这只是一种释放压力的方式，有时甚至和你的兄弟姐妹吵一架或大吵一架也是一种爱的表现。
My biggest advice to you as an only child, looking at the situation being like, this is so abnormal and weird, is to disengage. Don't get involved. Don't give advice. Don't try and mediate. Trust me, it's like getting between two dogs that are fighting. Like, you're just going to get hurt. It's just going to be projected on you.
作为独生子女，你看着这种情况觉得“这太不正常、太诡异了”，我给你的最大建议就是抽身出来。不要介入。不要给建议。不要试图调解。相信我，这就好比夹在两只打架的狗中间。结果就是你会受伤。负面情绪只会投射到你身上。
This is a sibling thing. unless your boyfriend asks for advice, unless he is seriously, emotionally or mentally distressed by arguments he's having with his sister, just let them sort it out. And I promise you this is the other factor in this. It gets better with age and it gets better with time because they will start seeing more eye-to-eye. And as we get older, we just get less snappy and irritable. Especially I'm thinking about my relationship with my siblings. Oh gosh, we fought so much when we were kids.
这是兄弟姐妹之间的事情。除非你男友主动寻求建议，除非他因为和姐姐的争吵而在情感或心理上受到严重困扰，否则就让他们自己去解决。我向你保证，这里还有另一个影响因素：随着年龄和时间的推移，情况会变好，因为他们会开始有更多的共识。随着我们年龄的增长，我们变得不那么急躁和易怒了。特别是当我想起我与兄弟姐妹的关系时。哦天哪，我们小时候吵得太厉害了。
And like, it was violent and it was aggressive and it was intense. But nowadays we are a lot better because we've matured. So it will get better with time. You're doing a great job. I'm sure it's scary. Just disengage and let them sort their own shit out. The second question I got from a listener, do only children's brains develop any differently to people with siblings?
而且，这很暴力、很有攻击性、很激烈。但现在我们好多了，因为我们成熟了。所以随着时间推移情况会变好的。你做得很好。我确信这很吓人。只要抽身出来，让他们自己去解决他们那些破事。我收到的第二个听众的问题是：独生子女的大脑发育跟有兄弟姐妹的人有什么不同吗？
No. No. There we go. That's the answer. Being an only sibling comes down to nurture. It's part of your environment. not part of your nature and nature genetic blueprint, cellular blueprint is normally what influences,
没有。没有。好了。这就是答案。成为独生子女归根结底是后天养育的问题。这是你环境的一部分。而不是你的先天本性和先天遗传蓝图、细胞蓝图，这通常是影响
well, not normally it is, what influences and determines how your brain will develop. Only children and eldest children, middle children, youngest children, if I put their brains in front of a scientist, they would not be able to distinguish between them. Our third question, are there differences between only children raised by both parents compared to a single parent? I think I mentioned, slightly mentioned this before, but I'm very glad that we got a specific question on it because it's an excellent question.
好吧，不是通常，它就是影响和决定你大脑发育的因素。如果我把独生子女、长子、中间子女、老幺的大脑放在科学家面前，他们是无法区分开的。我们的第三个问题是：由双亲抚养长大的独生子女与单亲抚养的独生子女有什么区别吗？我想我之前稍微提到过这一点，但我很高兴我们收到了一个针对性的问题，因为这是一个极好的问题。
I think being a single parent is tough because sometimes you feel like you have to do the job of two parents, not really realizing that the love you're giving is totally enough. If you are an only child with a single parent, you may find that you have a much more extremely close bond compared to some of your friends or some examples that you see. You know, one of my sister's best friends is an only child to a single parent. And wow, like her relationship with her mom is so beautiful and wonderful. And you know what? Me and my mom are most certainly not that close. And I am happy to admit that.
我认为单亲抚养很艰难，因为有时你会觉得你必须承担两个父母的工作，却没有真正意识到你给予的爱其实完全足够。如果你是一个单亲家庭的独生子女，你可能会发现与某些朋友或你看到的一些例子相比，你们有着更加极端亲密的纽带。你知道，我姐姐的一个好朋友就是一个单亲家庭的独生子女。哇，比如她跟她妈妈的关系是如此美丽和奇妙。你知道吗？我和我妈妈绝对没有那么亲密。我很乐意承认这一点。
there is also an increased chance of that parentification dynamic taking place because obviously if you have a single parent especially if your mom or your dad is not dating anyone or doesn't have that large of a support network or hasn't remarried you kind of become their emotional support system you become something that they can rely on I don't think it's their fault right it's just because they're so close to you and they love you and they trust you and they don't have anyone else to lean on, you can become the adult sometimes in that situation. So it's something definitely to watch out for. I think also the financial constraints of having an only, sorry, having a single parent as an only child may be more intense, potentially leading to more stress and
这种父母化的动态发生的几率也更高，因为显然如果你是单亲家庭，特别是如果你的妈妈或爸爸没有在约会，或者没有那么大的支持网络，或者没有再婚，你不知不觉就成了他们的情感支持系统，你成了他们可以依赖的对象。我不认为这是他们的错，对吧？只是因为他们和你太亲近了，他们爱你，信任你，而且没有其他人可以依靠，有时在这种情况下你就会变成成年人。所以这绝对是需要注意的事情。我认为单亲家庭作为独生子女也可能会面临更严峻的财务限制，这可能导致更多的压力和
earlier independence. We already know that only children are quite independent. Having a single parent may increase that as well. The parent may be more protective. There may be more pressure, more pressure to succeed. You may feel greater responsibility to be everything for the parent. And sometimes you may be more lonely because, you know, if your single parent has to work, you may have to hang out at home more. You may have the house to yourself more instead of having, you know, both your parents there taking it in turns or being more present for you. I will say I don't think that there is like any difference in long term outcomes. Single parent, two parents doesn't really matter as long as they really, as long as they
更早的独立。我们已经知道独生子女相当独立。单亲家庭可能会进一步加剧这一点。父母可能会更有保护欲。可能会有更大的压力，追求成功的压力更大。你可能会觉得有更大的责任成为父母的一切。有时你可能会更孤独，因为，你知道，如果你的单亲父母必须工作，你可能不得不更多地独自呆在家里。你可能更多时候是独自一人呆在家里，而不是有双亲都在那里轮流照顾你或更多地陪伴你。我要说的是，我认为长期结果没有任何区别。单亲还是双亲其实并不重要，只要他们真的、只要他们
love you and care about you. You can have one parent and they're going to do the job of seven parents. They could do the job of 10 parents if they are a great parent. So yeah, I love this question. Those are the differences I could immediately think of. This next question is funny. Why is it that every only child I've mentioned? met has fit the stereotype of being a little bit spoiled. This is so funny because obviously we've
爱你并且关心你。你可以只有一个父母，但他们能干七个父母的活。如果他们是一个伟大的父母，他们甚至能干十个父母的活。所以，是的，我很喜欢这个问题。这些是我能立刻想到的区别。下一个问题很有趣。为什么我遇到的每一个独生子女都符合有点被宠坏的刻板印象？这太有趣了，因为显然我们已经
broken this down. I think it's confirmation bias. I think it's confirmation bias. I think that you have been told that this is what to expect from these types of individuals. And so now you only pay attention to their behavior or to the behavior that meets your expectation, not the behaviors that don't. So for example, the times when your only child friend or your only children friends are not selfish or are not jealous or are not dominating, which is probably the majority of the time, you know, that you don't really pay attention to that as much as the times when they are. And those times that they are, which we all have feel more significant to you. So they become the whole reality.
对此进行了剖析。我认为这是确认偏误。我认为这是确认偏误。我想，是因为你被告知应该从这类人身上期待这种表现，所以现在你只关注他们的行为，或者只关注那些符合你期望的行为，而忽略那些不符合的行为。举个例子，你的独生子女朋友不自私、不嫉妒、不专横的时候，这可能占了大多数时间，你知道，你其实并不会像关注他们自私的时候那样去关注这些时刻。而他们自私的那些时刻——我们所有人都有过——对你来说感觉更重要。所以它们成了全部的现实。
It may also just be that that's just who they are. It doesn't have anything to do with being an only child. They just are kind of your friends just happen to be a bit selfish. Maybe it's the impact of culture or context. It may simply be that the only children you are meeting
这也可能只是因为他们就是这样的人。这跟是不是独生子女没有任何关系。他们只是碰巧有点自私。也许这是文化或背景的影响。这可能仅仅是因为你遇到的独生子女
are just better at advocating for themselves and sometimes we confuse that with being spoiled or selfish. So a couple of options there for answers. So the final question I got is do only children wish they had siblings? Now, I'm not an only child, so I can't answer this. I want to hear from you guys. I want to pose this question to the listeners because I want
更擅长为自己争取利益，而有时我们把这混淆成了被宠坏或自私。所以这里有几个备选答案。所以我收到的最后一个问题是：独生子女希望自己有兄弟姐妹吗？现在，我不是独生子女，所以我无法回答这个问题。我想听听你们大家的意见。我想把这个问题抛给听众，因为我想
to answer it as much as the person who posed it as an only child. Do you wish you had siblings? Are you envious of people who have siblings? Do you feel like you've missed out? Also remember to drop your imaginary friend name so that we can get a little gang going in the in the comment section have a little community of imaginaries going on and honestly I think with that question in mind that I'm posing to you all I have nothing else to say I think that's all my facts figures and research for the day on only children but I actually loved loved putting this episode together the research is so fascinating I loved diving into the history of our stereotypes I love diving into the dating and the career advice and information that I got from far and wide.
像提出这个问题的独生子女一样去回答它。你希望自己有兄弟姐妹吗？你嫉妒有兄弟姐妹的人吗？你觉得自己错过了什么吗？也别忘了留下你想象中的朋友的名字，这样我们就可以在评论区拉起一个小帮派，建立一个小小的“想象朋友”社群。老实说，带着我抛给你们大家的这个问题，我没有什么要补充的了，我想这就是我今天关于独生子女的所有事实、数据和研究。但实际上我非常非常喜欢把这一期节目拼凑起来，这项研究太迷人了，我喜欢深入探讨我们刻板印象的历史，我喜欢深入探讨我从四面八方获得的约会和职业建议与信息。
So if you enjoyed this episode, share it with another only child friend you may have. Share it to your story even better. Leave a five-star review the best. And make sure you're following along for when new episodes come out. We've got so much cool stuff leading up to the book being in your hands. So I can't wait for you all to tune in. And until next time, stay safe, be kind and be gentle with yourself. above all else, we will talk very, very soon.
所以，如果你喜欢这一期节目，把它分享给你可能认识的另一个独生子女朋友。更好的是，分享到你的快拍上。留下五星好评就最棒了。并确保关注我们，以便在新节目发布时收到通知。在图书送到你们手中之前，我们有很多很酷的内容。所以我等不及你们收听了。在下次节目之前，请保持安全，保持善良，对你自己好一点。最重要的是，我们很快就会再聊。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
收听《2%》。也就是IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的TWO。在《Look Back at It》播客中。对于1979年，对我来说那是一个大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是山姆·杰克（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员以及我们最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是一个疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
你正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hardway》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, Alessian, Michael Nanchini. My mind was blown.
兰斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支由网络侦探组成的军队来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）、迈克尔·南奇尼（Michael Nanchini）。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档iHeart播客。真人保证。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。